bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public euro de vous
retrouver pour 90 minutes de débats de
reportage et d'expertise la promesse est
dans le titre vous le savez donner du
sens à l'actualité vous proposez des
clés de compréhension des mutations de
notre société faut-il que les
responsables politiques se montrent plus
transparent sur leur vie privée cette
question nous vous l'avons posé avec nos
partenaires du baromètre odoxal vous
verrez dans un instant que les
sympathisants de la gauche radical ils
sont particulièrement sensibles ce sera
dans notre premier débat 100% politique
où l'on parlera aussi de la cote de
popularité d'Elizabeth borne et de cette
enquête ouverte aujourd'hui sur le
financement de la campagne
présidentielle de Valérie Pécresse et
puis pour notre second débat on va
commenter cette phrase nous vivons et
cela pas simplement depuis cet été ces
dernières années au fond la fin de ce
qui pouvait apparaître comme une
abondance
la fin de l'abondance la formule
d'Emmanuel Macron pour annoncer l'ère de
la sobriété énergétique à évidemment
concentré les critiques de ces opposants
on va l'analyser à court terme peut-on
passer l'hiver sans coupure
d'électricité et à long terme peut-on se
passer du nucléaire pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone en 2050 les réponses
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
les effets de l'affaire catenas sur la
popularité de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et sa
dévisse Audrey bettaz
c'est un soutien coûte politiquement
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon la semaine
dernière il salue le courage d'Adrien
député de sa formation qui vient de se
mettre en retrait après la révélation
d'une main courante déposée par sa
conjointe dans la foulée le leader de la
France insoumise dégringole dans les
enquêtes d'opinion moins 6 points auprès
des Français et pire moins 8 points
auprès des sympathisants de gauche plus
encore que la chute d'Adrien lui-même -
4 points sur ce sujet ça fait 15 ans que
je fais de la politique avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à intervalles réguliers on
cherche à instrumentaliser une crise on
me dit que sa cote de popularité baisse
qui les finit et puis la dernière fois
nous a fait ça au moment des
perquisitions vous en rappelez Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il a fait 22% des voix le plus
gros score qu'il a jamais réalisé à
l'élection présidentielle quoi qu'il en
soit la France insoumise semble souffrir
du syndrome de l'arrosoir arrosé après
avoir vivement critiqué les affaires de
mœurs des autres formations les Français
semblent déçus de voir le parti rattrapé
par des affaires similaires il faut dire
qu'ils sont 69 100% a souhaité que les
responsables politiques se montrent
davantage transparents sur la vie privée
l'exemplarité est d'abord demandé en
matière d'argent loin devant les mœurs
et la non-violence depuis les années
80-90 et une des politisations grosso
modo avec la fin des idéologies avec le
sentiment que le politique ne pouvait
pas changer le réel et bien les Français
se sont repliés sur une approche d'abord
gestionnaire du politique et puis
ensuite en réalité très morale de la
politique si le politique n'est qu'un
gestionnaire on demande au moins aux
politiques d'être honnêtes et d'être
honnête à la fois dans son aspect public
gestion des données mais également dans
son aspect privé vu comme étant un
élément complémentaire et cette attente
ne semble pas satisfaite 87% des
Français pensent que le comportement des
politiques ne sait pas amélioré ces
dernières années pourtant il n'y a
jamais eu autant de loi et d'outils de
contrôle un exemple la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
créée en 2013 après l'affaire Cahuzac
beaucoup d'enseignements à attiré de ce
baromètre
odoxa mascara pour LCP Assemblée
Nationale publique Sénat et la presse
quotidienne régionale j'accueille Gal
Slimane bonsoir bienvenue le président
est co-fondateur de doxa Alexia Germont
bonsoir et bienvenue dans du cercle de
réflexion France audacieuse Frédéric
potier bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
expert associés à la Fondation Jean
Jaurès et Laetitia cruppa et politique
bonsoir et bienvenue Laetitia je redonne
ce chiffre qu'on a vu rapidement Gael
Slimane dans le dans le sujet d'Audrey
69% des Français qui répondent oui à la
question faut-il que les responsables
politiques soient se montrent plus
transparent et lorsqu'il est intéressant
si on rentre un peu dans le détail c'est
81% des sapatisants de la gauche
radicale le moins qu'on puisse dire
depuis deux semaines ils sont servis les
sympathisants de la gauche radicale oui
ils sont servis tout a été très bien
résumé sur sur le les données du
baromètre comme comme toujours dans le
dans ce qu'on a entendu et on voit bien
l'articulation de tout ça c'est à une
affaire qui concerne une personnalité
demande des éminents des insoumis et de
la nupesse et des prises de position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui suscitent un buzz
médiatique parfois le buzz médiatique
surtout sur des affaires qui touchent à
la vie intime au privé au mœurs on peut
appeler ça comme on veut bien souvent ça
n'a pas d'impact dans l'opinion là ça
n'est pas le cas et ça n'est pas le cas
justement pour ce que vous venez de dire
parce qu'il y a une attente importante
d'exemplarité en matière politique mais
on attend surtout de l'exemplarité chez
ceux qui donnent des leçons aux autres
et là en l'occurrence ce qui fracasse la
popularité ou la côte d'adhésion de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de d'à peu près
tous les membres de son parti dans le
baromètre d'ailleurs c'est le fait que
ils ont été en première ligne pour
dénoncer des comportements parfois
supposés chez certains de leurs
adversaires politiques des gens qui ont
contesté les faits qui on peut penser à
Damien Abba donc on peut penser à au
ministre de l'Intérieur maintenant à
plein d'autres ils ont été extrêmement
virulents pour les autres et quand
quelque chose les touche même là le
sentiment et c'est ce qu'enregistre
notamment mascara sur les réseaux
sociaux il parle d'arroseur arrosé parce
que sur les réseaux sociaux il y a des
remontées extrêmement violentes de
militants et beaucoup de militantes
féministes de l'univers leur base leur
base leur propre en fait c'est pas du
win-win c'est du loose loose on a à la
fois des critiques de la part des gens
qui ne sont pas proches d'eux et qui
disent c'était bien la peine de donner
des leçons à tout le monde si finalement
vous n'êtes pas plus blanc que les
autres et on a des réactions très
virulentes de la part de leur base qui
disent mais comment est-ce possible que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon fasse ce tweet parce
qu'à la limite il aurait pu prendre une
posture neutre en disant qu'il prend
acte de la décision d'Adrien catenas ne
pas en rajouter s'il ne voulait pas
enfoncer Adrien katnas mais faire ce
tweet dans lequel il salue le courage
d'Adrien katnas sur une affaire reconnue
par Adrien katnas lui-même comme étant
une affaire de violence conjugale et de
Gif donné à sa femme ce qu'il a reconnu
lui-même
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
incompréhensible pour une bonne partie
des gens qui sont des soutiens de la
nuit passe alors j'entendais Emmanuel
Bompard et j'en termine par là dire on
nous a déjà fait le coup de mélange mais
en fait c'est pas un coup c'est que ça
s'est produit de la même chose il a tout
à fait raison au moment du fameux la
République c'est moi lors de la
perquisition il sait effondré dans les
enquêtes et il a mis des mois et des
mois à remonter la pente alors manuel
bon pas à raison il faut pas enterrer
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est remonté il a
su remonté la pente il a su rebondir il
a su
reprendre vie dans les sondages et dans
les élections mais il a une traversée du
désert très longue on pourrait lui
souhaiter si on s'appelait manuel
Bompard et bien que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ne connaisse pas pareil durée de
traverser du désert donc ce baromètre il
est fait après l'affaire cadenas mais
avant l'histoire
Julien Bayou on est bien d'accord donc
ça c'est un peu ça c'est un peu croisé
on était au début puisque on a terminé
le terrain vendredi dernier donc on
était au début de il va faire Bayou on
en parlait déjà de l'affaire Bayou avec
ça vous faites la différence tiens
d'ailleurs entre ces deux affaires
est-ce que certains disent c'est pas
l'affaire Bayou c'est l'affaire Rousseau
oui pour moi c'est pas c'est pas du tout
le même type le même type d'affaires
juste pour rebondir sur déjà ce que vous
disiez Gaëlle ce que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant dans le sondage c'est que il
y avait cette notion de trahison du
pacte de responsabilité et ça je crois
qu'on est au cœur on parle d'exemplarité
on parle aussi d'Adrien catenas qui
était qui faisait figure de dauphins et
donc la chute est encore plus
fracassante et pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a vraiment cette notion à la fois
de soutien qui était à contretemps et de
la forme du soutien qui était encore
plus maladroite et impardonnable pour
quelqu'un qui a son expérience politique
je ferme la parenthèse parce que mais
qu'il a assumé mais qu'il a assumé
vraiment mais enfin cela dit
des journalistes comme il a fait
déjà su le faire plusieurs fois vous
l'aviez testé d'ailleurs il y a quelques
années dans une émission média qu'on
faisait ensemble bref femme la
parenthèse non les deux affaires ne sont
pas identiques et je pense que quand on
parle de l'affaire Rousseau plutôt que
de la faire Julien Bayou
c'est pas totalement infondé parce qu'on
voit bien que c'est ça qui est
particulièrement gênant c'est que
ces affaires là sont suffisamment graves
pour qu'on ait pas besoin d'en rajouter
et moi évidemment avec mon prisme
professionnel d'avocat je ne suis pas
favorable
à l'institution de commission au sein de
partis politiques parce que je trouve
que je fais confiance j'ai confiance en
la justice de mon pays quand il y a des
des actes qui sont commis et qu'il y a
des délits qui sont supposés on saisit
la justice ça prend du temps peut-être
mais on a tout l'arsenal juridique à
disposition et et il est à mon avis un
justifié de créer des niveaux de
responsabilité qui mettent d'ailleurs
les personnes qui sont aux commandes de
ces de ces commissions dans des
positions totalement en porte-à-faux et
ses affaires sont suffisamment graves
pour qu'elles soient traitées par des
magistrats professionnels si ça doit
être
poursuivi l'un n'étant pas exclusif de
l'autre mais on voit bien d'ailleurs que
la problématique à laquelle on se réfère
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez un
télescopage avec en plus des affaires
qui sont politiques là parce que
vraiment il faut pas prendre les gens
pour plus idiot qu'ils ne le sont on
voit bien qu'en ce qui concerne
l'affaire
il y a quand même un congrès qui se
profile donc on voit bien que les
conditions dans lesquelles ça a été mise
en avant sont des conditions qui ne sont
pas
endroit
justifié et le garder sur le ministre de
la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit attention à la
justice de droit privé cet après-midi je
vous propose aussi d'écouter la réaction
du philosophe Raphaël Enthoven c'était
ce matin sur RTL était le sexisme
structurel d'une société patriarcale
depuis des siècles n'excuse pas ou
n'autorise pas la façon dont Sandrine
Rousseau s'est débarrassé de Julien
Bayou ou la publiquement pardon de le
dire comme ça exécuter je vais au bout
de ma phrase ça ne lui donne pas raison
comment dire elle n'est pas excusable de
ses procédés par la nature du système au
sein duquel elle se trouve il y a des
lois il y a des façons de faire il y a
des gens dont la dignité ou dans
l'honneur dépend de la façon dont on
présente les choses elle ne peut pas
fonctionner comme ça parce qu'elle fait
reculer la cause qu'elle prétend faire
avancer en faisant ça en se conduisant
comme ça les gens entendent ça
immédiatement au lieu de s'indigner
d'éventuels violences psychologiques
exercées par un homme sur une femme il
s'indigne de la façon dont une femme
pour Robespierre exécute un rival
politique c'est ça le scandale le
scandale aujourd'hui c'est Rousseau
c'est pas bayou
ça correspond exactement à ce que je
pense de cette affaire
est-ce que j'aurais peut-être qu'on
aille un peu plus loin parce qu'on parle
de de cette exigence de transparence et
d'exemplarités de la part de de nos
politiques quel trace profonde peuvent
laisser ces deux dossiers ou ces deux
affaires appelés comme comme vous le
souhaitez d'abord ce que je trouve très
étonnant c'est l'impression
d'amateurisme et d'improvisation on
découvre pas aujourd'hui les affaires
MiTo les vagues de libération de la
parole des victimes femmes on découvre
pas des affaires PPDA et il y a même des
lois il les lois imposent aux grandes
entreprises aux administrations d'avoir
des référents harcèlement sexuels
d'avoir des procédures d'alerte d'avoir
des protections de ses lanceurs d'alerte
et là on a l'impression que chez les
partis politiques et des partis
politiques très en pointe sur ces
questions et bien c'est le tout début de
la réflexion sur ces sujets là et ça je
trouve que c'est très étonnant et
effectivement c'est normal que ça heurte
un électorat de gauche un électorat
jeune aussi une victoire jeune se
retrouve beaucoup chez Mélenchon et chez
les Verts et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
un malaise assez impressionnant qui
renvoie d'ailleurs je trouve ces
organisations alors propre alors propre
structure
un coup d’œil on l'a vu mais je voudrais
qu'on rentre dans le détail sur la côte
d'adhésion de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Gael
Slimane elle est à 22% chez tous les
Français avec une baisse de 6 points
mais là encore ça rejoint ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure la baisse elle est
encore plus forte chez les sympathisants
de gauche il est à 55 pour cent de côte
d'adhésion mais il perd 8 points là
encore comment on peut analyser parce
que bon on sait tous Voilà l'actualité
un scandale chasse l'autre etc etc on va
parler tout à l'heure de de cette
enquête préliminaire ouverte pour sur le
financement de la campagne
présidentielle de Valérie Pécresse mais
les effets à long terme comment vous
vous pouvez les les anticiper ou les
imaginer notamment dans l'électorat de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et c'est parti de la
nuque en fait ça va vous surprendre mais
je l'ai dit d'un mot tout à l'heure mais
il faut écouter manuel vous montriez
l'extrait tout à l'heure et il nous
disait mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon s'est
remis on a voulu l'enterrer
rappelez-vous au moment de la
perquisition et bien c'est un très bon
exemple en fait alors pas comme lui
l'entend évidemment il pourrait répondre
à votre question je pense que ce qui
fait défaut dans l'opinion parce que moi
c'est mon bien sûr de la je parle ce qui
fait défaut à Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans
l'opinion c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
à dire que j'ai toujours considéré en
regardant nos études que c'était une
immense fragilité que la personnalité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour la réussite de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'homme politique et
pour la réussite du mouvement ou de la
coalition qu'il portait moyennant quoi
dommage pour la gauche ou la gauche
radicale ou l'ensemble des gauches il se
trouve que la personnalité la plus
saillante la plus talentueuse celle qui
était la plus en situation de pouvoir
fédérer
l'envie des électeurs de gauche de faire
un score supérieur à 5% à la
présidentielle c'était Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais rappelez-vous dans les
intentions de vote quand on en parlait
ici les gens connaissent par cœur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils la découverte la
dernière présidentielle il était à 7 8%.
qu'est-ce qui explique qu'il soit passé
de 7 8% à 10 puis 12 puis 15 et ainsi de
suite tout simplement que
progressivement les électeurs de gauche
se sont dit tant pis je n'aime pas la
personnalité de Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
qu'il me semble dangereux parce qu'il me
semble trop éruptif parce qu'il a des
défauts qui me font peur mais il faut
bien voter utile à gauche et c'est comme
ça qu'il a pu capitaliser sur le vote de
gauche donc ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est exactement la même chose
c'est à dire que je crains pour lui que
ça n'aboutit à ce qui s'est passé au
moment de la perquisition c'est-à-dire
qu'il dégringole durablement et que
cette fois peut-être il ne se relève pas
juste d'un mot sur Sandrine Rousseau et
le débat est-ce que c'est une affaire
Bayou une affaire Rousseau on a une
autre personnalité qui s'effondre de
manière extrêmement impressionnante dans
nos enquêtes pour les raisons que vous
évoquez l'un et l'autre je pense c'est
Sandrine Rousseau alors Julien Bayou il
est inconnu donc on l'a testé pour la
première fois là 7% de côte d'adhésion
mais la plupart des gens qui ne disent
pas adhérer à un bayou sont des gens qui
disent je sais pas qui c'est j'en ai
jamais entendu parler Sandrine Rousseau
quand même elle se hisse elle fait plus
8 points de code de rejet de personnes
qui disent en gros la détester et elle
se hisse sur quasiment le podium des
champions du rejet historique
c'est-à-dire Éric Zemmour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon justement et Marine Le Pen
donc dans l'affaire Bayou Rousseau c'est
effectivement plutôt probablement
Sandrine ou soit peut-être que Bayou du
coup ça l'empêchera de décoller
puisqu'il était pas trop connu avant
mais en tout cas Sandrine Rousseau elle
empathie parce que le sentiment général
c'est qu'effectivement elle s'est érigée
en procureur en Saint-Just en
Robespierre et elle a flingué un
adversaire politique en se servant de
quelque chose d'une cause qui est quand
même une cause qui mérite d'être
défendue autrement alors on va prendre
un petit peu de recul avec vous Laetitia
dans le temps puisque la moralisation de
la vie politique c'était l'une des
grandes promesses pour ne pas dire la
grande promesse de d'Emmanuel Macron en
2017 ça a fonctionné ça n'a pas
fonctionné oui dans les faits ça a
fonctionné pourquoi parce que déjà il
obtient entre les deux tours le soutien
de François Bayrou que à ce moment là il
y a le Pénélope gate qui fait chuter
François Fillon et que ça lui permet
Emmanuel Macron challenger des
challenger de d'être élu président de la
République donc tout naturellement dès
qu'il arrive à l'Élysée il lance ce
grand chantier de la moralisation de la
vie politique et il le fait avec une
communication à l'américaine c'est la
première fois qu'un président français
signe en direct à la télévision les
textes de loi regardez la séquence
il s'agit donc là de deux textes
importants la loi pour la confiance dans
la vie politique et la loi organique
pour la confiance dans la vie politique
que je viens de signer qui sont donc
aujourd'hui
promulgués c'est de lois ce sont des
engagements de campagne importants
qui constituent une vraie rénovation de
notre vie politique
l'impossibilité d'embaucher un membre de
sa famille
est ainsi maintenant promulguée
l'impossibilité d'être élu quand on a un
casier judiciaire B2 et promulgué
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
ont dit ou peuvent encore croire ce que
nous avions promis nous l'avons fait
bon à l'époque sur les réseaux c'était
un peu gaussé de cet image bancal où on
n'a jamais su qui tournait et puis de
l'école Belloubet et de Christophe
Castaner qui faisait un peu à plantes
vertes mais le message en tout cas de
l'exécutif était passé le message était
clair nous avons tenu nos promesses et
d'ailleurs en introduction d'un des
textes il était noté notre vie publique
a besoin d'un choc de confiance oui
alors vous avez fait référence à la
campagne présidentielle évidemment le
pays upgate mais il y avait eu aussi
pendant le mandat de de François
Hollande des lois contre la fraude
fiscale contre la corruption et puis
évidemment l'affaire Cahuzac voilà et
c'est pas pour ça qu'Emmanuel Macron
s'engouffre dans cette promesse de la
République exemplaire avec par exemple
il l'a dit elle a un mais l'interdiction
des emplois familiaux pour les
parlementaires la limitation du nombre
de mandats consécutifs ou encore le
contrôle de leur frais professionnels
mais
Thomas 5 ans après c'est vrai que le
principe absolu de la probité en
politique n'a pas toujours été respectée
alors il y a quand même eu quelques
départs fracassants c'est vrai que le
premier est certainement le plus
symbolique c'est celui de François
Bayrou c'est quand même lui le monsieur
de cette loi c'est lui de rédacteur de
cette loi il part des le mois de juin
2017 à cause de cette enquête sur les
emplois fictifs du MoDem au Parlement
européen et puis dans la suite de
François Bayrou il y a le départ de
Richard Ferrand mise en cause dans
l'affaire des mutuelles de Bretagne mais
le principe d'exemplarité c'est
complètement fracassé sur l'affaire
Benalla pourquoi parce que le président
Emmanuel Macron le soutient coûte que
coûte pendant plusieurs semaines quitte
même à critiquer ouvertement les
journalistes donc pour vous ça a rompu
une forme de liens de confiance oui si
un tech il y en ait eu un à un moment
donné complètement parce qu'ensuite il y
a eu quelques largesses on va dire par
exemple avant d'obtenir un long lieu
Richard Ferrand devient président de
l'Assemblée nationale alors qu'il est
mis en examen
idem pour Gérald Darmanin avant aussi de
bénéficier de non-lieu il est nommé
ministre de l'Intérieur en 2020 alors
qu'il y a deux plaintes pour viol contre
lui et aujourd'hui même Thomas dans le
cercle très privé d'Emmanuel Macron
Alexis colère et Thierry Soler un
conseiller spécial officieux on va dire
qui joue un rôle fondamental sont
eux-mêmes inquiétées par la justice
alors je pose la question ce soir
peut-être que ces lois qui sont écrites
ne sont pas écrites par les bonnes
personnes puisque elles sont écrites par
cela même sur qui le soupçon est jeté
effectivement et alors ça va être
intéressant en Gaëlle de tout continuer
de creuser le le l'opinion face à ces
questions transparence et d'exemplarités
si on regarde les domaines dans lesquels
l'exemplarité et le est la plus attendue
de la part des responsables politiques
c'est l'argent qui vient en premier
67% bien avant les mœurs oui alors on
avait plusieurs réponses possibles mais
il fallait quand même choisir demander
aux personnes interrogées de choisir les
domaines pour lesquels ils attendaient
le plus cet exemplarité de la part des
hommes politiques exemplarité qui est
très important pour les Français
puisqu'on avait une autre question dans
le sondage qu'il montrait et il nous
disent effectivement que c'est en
matière d'argent que ce soit les
déclarations fiscales les emplois
déclarés etc d'ailleurs vous avez vu
Emmanuel Macron l'a d'ailleurs dit dans
l'extrait que l'on voit en disant un
homme politique ne pourra plus embaucher
une personne de sa famille on est
vraiment tourné autour de ça les en
matière demeure on est un cran en
dessous et en matière écologique de non
violence de probité ça existe quand même
tout ça apparaît on peut retenir que
tout est important mais que l'argent est
vraiment central là-dedans et ce qui est
intéressant dans dans ce que vient de
dire Laetitia c'est que
en vrai si je puis dire probablement que
depuis 95 en vérité les hommes
politiques sont plus honnêtes qu'il y a
moins de magouille qu'il y a moins de de
contournement des lois versarait évident
c'est une quasi certitude ne serait-ce
que parce que maintenant il y a les feux
de l'actualité les feux des projecteurs
qui sont sur eux parce que il y a tout
un tas de lois qui existent mais en même
temps il est impossible d'y échapper si
on fait un pas de côté et il y en a
toujours un qui pourra se faire
rattraper mais ça veut dire que
l'observation elle est pas forcément
perçue par les Français c'est ça
l'amélioration dans notre dans notre
sondage on a posé cette question et moi
je suis persuadé que les Français se
trompent mais on s'en fiche ce qui
compte c'est pour traiter les exactement
les faits sociaux comme des choses et là
on a 87% des Français qui nous disent
ils sont soit moins exemplaires qu'avant
les politiques qu'avant là ils sont 44 à
le dire soit ça n'a pas changé ça ne
s'est pas améliorer et ceux qui pensent
qu'ils sont un peu plus exemplaires
qu'autrefois ne sont que 13%. donc on
voit bien que les chocs de confiance
c'est même l'inverse c'est à force de
mettre en avant un sujet c'est la même
chose que ce qu'on a observé pour
Mélenchon Rousseau Bayou à force de
focaliser sur une thématique même si ça
se passe moins mal qu'avant le niveau
d'exigence augmente et du coup le
résultat c'est que les gens ont
l'impression que tous se dégrade est-ce
qu'il y a une forme de d'injustice
finalement dans selon vos exagère dans
cette perception des Français je sais
pas si c'est une injustice oui je sais
pas si c'est une injustice parce que ce
qui compte en bout de course c'est la
façon dont les gens ressentent les
choses c'est comme toujours quand on
regardait les questions du pouvoir
d'achat il y a à la fois les chiffres et
puis il y a la perception des chiffres
le ressenti et ce qui fait bouger nos
concitoyens c'est le ressenti c'est pas
les chiffres c'est heureusement qu'il y
a encore un peu de un peu de cœur et de
moi ce que j'ai trouvé aussi à souligner
dans le dans le sondage c'est d'abord le
besoin de transparence très étonnamment
et essentiellement par les plus de 65
ans et je trouve que ça ce n'est pas
quelque chose d'intuitif on est dans une
génération où les jeunes appellent à la
transparence tous les jours et
finalement c'est plutôt les personnes de
plus de 65 ans sont plus désintéressés
de la politique alors que alors plus
intéressant sur les questions de
transition écologique où voilà où la
fracture est tellement forte d'ailleurs
comme le reconnaissait Emmanuel Macron
lui-même sur cette fameuse interview
quand il était sur le Charles de Gaulle
où il disait ce que je n'ai pas réussi
lors du premier quinquennat c'est un
recoudre à retisser le lien finalement
des Français avec la politique et ça je
pense que c'est vraiment un point
central parce que ça a beaucoup de
déclinaisons et puis il y a une seconde
chose qui me paraît intéressante aussi
c'est que dans votre étude il y a une
sorte d'incohérence des Français à un
moment où vous avez à la fois ce besoin
de transparence très fort à plus de 60%
de mémoire 69 voilà et en même temps ce
qui vient en dernier c'est la probité le
transparence sur l'argent en fait
l'envie vraiment le focus sur l'argent
mais c'est plus ce que font les
politiques de leurs moyens financiers
mais finalement la probité c'est pas au
devant donc je trouve que c'est un peu
étonnant de voir cette et quelque part
l'exemplearité je finirai par là moi je
me demande si ce qui est évidemment
qu'on attend des politiques d'être
exemplaires mais surtout le plus
important c'est d'être en accord avec ce
que vous portez comme parole publique et
valeur dans le débat public et ce que
vous vous appliquez dans votre vie
personnelle c'est pas tant d'avoir une
transparence totale sur la vie
personnelle mais que quand il y a
quelque chose qui sort que ça soit
quelque chose qui soit en accord avec
vos convictions que vous portez dans le
débat public alors ça va forcément
alimenter ce mouvement d'opinion cette
enquête préliminaire ouverte par le
parquet de Paris sur la campagne
présidentielle de Valérie Pécresse en
quête pour détournement de fonds publics
Valérie qui a réagi cet après-midi et
elle réagit en attaquant en
contre-attaquant parce que cette enquête
elle démarre comment elle démarre sur un
signalement de rock Écologie Les Verts
et en l'occurrence de Julien Bayou
trouvé que tout cela est cocasse mais
bref et donc Valérie Pécresse elle
attaque le parti au pécologie vert pour
dénonciation quelle opinion écouter
c'est encore une dénonciation qui a le
mieux se dévers c'est leur méthode
l'emploi une nouvelle fois et moi je
fais toute confiance à la justice parce
que les règles ont été scrupuleusement
respectées pendant ma campagne de Julien
Bayou en l'occurrence
bon voilà c'est le début on va laisser
la justice faire son travail en essayant
d'être le plus serein et tranquille
possible mais il n'empêche que pour une
personnalité comme Valérie Pécresse qui
est déjà vous la testez même pas dans le
dans la liste des personnalités
d'une certaine façon c'est un boulet
qu'elle va forcément traîner que quelque
soit le l'issue de ces procédures qui
seront longues bien sûr et ce qui est
vraiment paradoxal et ça fait le lien
avec le sujet précédent c'est que on a
des lois qui ont été adoptées sur le
financement des campagnes électorales
alors que dans les années 80 c'était
c'était la jungle des détournements des
marchés publics sur lesquels on prélevé
une petite portion pour financer un
parti politique aujourd'hui la situation
elle a été considérablement assainie il
y a un contrôle de de la Commission
nationale des comptes et des
financements politiques du Conseil
constitutionnel
les dons sont plafonnés il y a une
interdiction de financement par
l'étranger et peut-être la brique qui
manque et ça c'était aussi un petit clin
d'oeil aux images qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure avec Nicole bilbé c'est
peut-être cette fameuse banque de la
démocratie qui était une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était voulue par
François Bayrou et qui n'a pas été
finalement mis dans cette loi mise en
scène loi et donc il manque aussi c'est
peut-être le contrôle parce que quand
vous dites pas d'ingérence étrangère et
pas de financement étranger pour
l'instant il y a quand même quelques
doutes sur plusieurs campagnes
absolument mais on n'est pas aux
États-Unis je pense que le poids de
l'argent sur nos campagnes électorales
et bien moins que dans beaucoup de pays
mais n'empêche que ce type d'accusation
ce type de procédure ça ça introduit un
doute ça alimente un climat très malsain
et à la fin ça donne des résultats comme
ceux que Gael vient d'expliquer sur
finalement une défiance politique très
forte pas toujours objective mais un
sentiment comme ça que les politiques
nous mentent ou prennent beaucoup de
largesse avec la légalité alors toujours
sur ces questions d'exemplarité et et de
transparence
ce qui est intéressant quand même Alexa
germon c'est de d'essayer c'est ce que
j'essaye depuis le début de
d'évaluer un effet un effet à long terme
pour une personnalité comme vous voyez
Pécresse qui vit vraiment une année
terrible quand on sait le score qu'elle
réalise à la présidentielle c'est elle
sort de cette présidentielle en dessous
des 5%, elle fait appel aux dons
pour voilà pour même personnellement
épongé ses dettes et voilà cette affaire
qui lui tombe dessus quel impact en
terme d'image en terme de de
structuration de de l'opinion et de et
du des sympathisants LR ça peut avoir
d'après vous alors je commencerai par un
premier impact qui est pour la personne
elle-même c'est que pour se défendre
c'est beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'énergie déjà donc ça vous met de côté
pas forcément en étant complètement de
côté mais ça vous prend je dirais de la
bande passante très significativement
pour avoir une défense qui est bien
orchestrée avec l'ensemble des
conseillers que vous ne manquez pas
d'avoir ça c'est le premier point et
c'est le plus immédiat pour moi et c'est
celui qui coûte le plus cher
immédiatement même s'il n'est pas vu des
Français et puis après derrière vous
avez l'impact réputationnel évidemment
l'impact ça c'est du côté de la personne
qui est visée vous avez également
l'impact à très long terme et qui est
très insidieux et que je pense très
grave sur l'état de la démocratie l'état
de nos institutions de la défiance de la
vie publique parce que
c'est vraiment tous les efforts qui sont
faits au quotidien par les élus qui sont
exemplaires pour la plupart d'entre eux
et qui travaillent vraiment pour le bien
commun c'est comme un château de cartes
dès qu'il y a une affaire comme ça ça
permet à une certaine partie de la
population d'exprimer son sa défiance on
mécontentement et il faut après
détricoter au quotidien donc je pense
que c'est
même s'il n'y a pas d'élection immédiate
c'est une fois de plus des maîtres et
des maîtres de distance qui se font avec
les politiques et vous le ressentez
après quand vous êtes sur le terrain
forcément donc c'est la première des
choses dont on vous on va vous parler
quel que soit les couleurs politiques
c'est pas le sujet c'est tous pourri il
y a pas de fumée
et tout ça ça fait que on est on se
détourne de l'explication
pédagogique qu'on doit avoir sur les
tenants et les aboutissants des des
réformes qui sont devant nous et qui
sont vraiment des réformes très
structurelles pour notre pays
aujourd'hui
l'état du pays nécessite que tous nos
efforts soient tournés vers une sortie
par le haut et c'est pas gagné et ça
fait monter les populistes
à mon avis ne serait absolument pas
exemplaire s'ils étaient au pouvoir
allez on a il nous reste un quart
d'heure un peu moins d'un quart d'heure
dans ce débat on va on a bien je pense
analyser la question de la transparence
et de l'exemplarité maintenant on va
être plus sur l'avenir des personnalités
ou des familles politiques et je
commence grâce à Quentin Calmet par la
nuque ou la nupaise bonsoir Quentin
bonsoir qui pourrait rapidement
traverser une zone de turbulences dans
la perspective des élections
sénatoriales expliquez-nous oui les
expressionnelles les prochaines
élections à se tenir en France en
septembre prochain elle s'annonce comme
un premier test de la cohésion de la nu
pour on l'a lu notamment aussi dans Le
Parisien ce matin la France insoumise
aimerait enfin avoir des élus et ici à
la Chambre haute car ça n'existe pas
encore les sénateurs et les filles on a
bien un groupe communiste mais pas de
LFI sauf que rappelez-vous le scénar il
renouvelé par moitié tous les trois ans
via un scrutin universel indirect en
clair ce sont les grands électeurs qui
votent à 95% les mers et les conseillers
municipaux la France insoumise ne
dispose que de très peu d'élus locaux
donc ce sera difficile pour ce parti
l'année prochaine seule façon d'y
arriver disposée d'accord électoraux
c'est à dire de continuer à disposer de
la Corée électorale de la nuque qui
avait été créée pour les législatives et
donc de faire liste commune avec le
Parti socialiste les communistes ou
encore les écologistes sauf qu'au PS par
exemple hors de question de se faire
humilier par les troupes de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon comme certains ont pu vivre
l'accord de la nu-pologie lative écoutez
Rachid temal un dessinateur socialistes
les plus critiques de cet accord lors de
discussion du sur législatives il y
avait quelques principes je pense qu'il
faut les reprendre d'abord c'était les
sortants c'était je crois qu'il faut
reprendre ce principe là et puis je
crois que les filles avaient demandé à
ce qu'on soit sur le score des uns des
autres aux présidentielles alors nous
lui répondons aujourd'hui alors
regardons les scores des municipales des
uns et des autres et je crois que c'est
là-dessus qu'on doit faire ces
négociations là voilà on repart donc du
score des municipales donc pas du tout
du score des présidentielles c'est
pratique pour le Parti socialiste qui
disposent encore d'un maillage
territorial et même chez les partisans
de cet accord Thomas on sent que les
rapports de force ont projet par rapport
au législative mais pas question de se
mettre ado la France insoumise s'ils
font liste à part ils peuvent diviser
les voies dans les départements qui est
la circonscription pour les
sénatorielles écoutez Rémi Cardon et lui
dans la Somme on est effectivement en
position de force maintenant comme le
dit patrickner soyons plutôt habiles
c'est-à-dire mettre des candidatures
pour mettre des candidatures contre des
sénateurs socialistes ça pour moi ça n'a
aucun sens voilà il faut vraiment
raisonner très pragmatique par rapport
au poids de chacun dans chaque
territoire voilà les socialistes qui ont
d'ailleurs une réunion ce soir avec les
sénateurs sortants et qui vont définir
comme cela une stratégie avec les
partenaires de la nuque cet automne pour
commencer la campagne au printemps de
l'année prochaine Thomas merci beaucoup
Quentin Frédéric potier je reviens vers
vous est-ce que c'est forcément le
destin de la nuque de ce briser sur les
prochaines échéances électorales soient
assez notoriales ou après les
européennes encore plus peut-être c'est
vrai Thomas qui a deux échéances
compliqué pour la Corée électorale
puisqu'il y a les sénatoires elle est
appris à les Européennes et ils sont que
c'est deux scrutins qui aident pas
forcément à forger des coalitions donc
le scrutin sénatorial c'est beaucoup de
campagnes de terrain donc faut des
sortants il faut les faire campagne dans
chaque commune chaque nuit chaque petit
village et là c'est vrai que les filles
et pas tellement en situation de force
pour imposer des candidatures sauf
peut-être dans quelques grandes villes
et départements urbains et l'autre
échéance qui arrive c'est les
européennes où il y a des désaccords
majeurs abyssaux entre les Verts quasi
fédéralis et les filles souverainissent
le PC et le PS donc c'est vrai que ça va
être des deux scrutins extrêmement
difficiles à préparer pour les
formations politiques gel Slimane c'est
voulu intervenir Laetitia juste une
petite question est-ce que sans Jean-Luc
Mélenchon la nuque la nupesse peut
encore tenir parce que là on se posait
la question de l'avenir de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon moi j'avais compris que
perdant il disait faites mieux c'est ce
qu'il a dit donc il se retirait de la
course apparemment il a encore là si il
s'effondre est-ce que vous disiez vous
château de cartes est-ce que de façon
assez logique la nupesse ne va pas
s'effondrer aussi je vous laisse cette
question je rajoute la mienne est-ce que
est-ce que les Français la perçoivent
toujours comme une alliance de
circonstance la nuque alors pour la
première question c'est très compliqué
d'y répondre parce que je rebondirai ce
que je disais tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il est à la fois un formidable atout
pour que la gauche fasse un bon score à
une présidentielle et déjà pour une
présidentielle un grand handicap à cause
de sa personnalité éruptive tonitruante
dit voilà clivante donc peut-être
paradoxalement qu'une nupes parce que
c'est aussi politique de dire du puni
baisse nouvelle union populaire
écologiste et socialiste social et oui
donc il y a bien un s à la fin que et
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon voulait faire
oublier parce qu'initialement lui il
avait un mouvement qui s'appelait Nupe
donc moi je m'appuie sur l'Académie
française
[Musique]
non mais je sais bien ce que je veux
dire c'est que chez Mélenchon s'en est
un d'accord et en l'occurrence par
rapport à notre sujet il a une envie
hégémoniste sur cette alliance de la
gauche peut-être que la gauche pourrait
survivre à la retraite de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et sortir de là finalement
quelque chose qui existerait réellement
parce que très sérieusement depuis la
fin du quinquennat de François Hollande
il y a plus tellement ce qui est la
gauche quand on interroge dans les
sondages le peuple de gauche il est un
petit peu perdu et je crois que vous
avez bien sûr tout à fait raison sur ce
que vous disiez sur les échéances
électorales qui se prête plus ou moins
bien à une coalition celle qui viennent
s'y prête plutôt moins donc peut-être
que ce sera le moment pour la gauche de
ce réformer de faire émerger des
personnalités nouvelles alors ce sera
pas Adrien katnas probablement mais
aussi de construire un et aussi de
construire un socle commun d'idées qui
pourra fonctionner parce que c'est ce
qu'on avait vu à la présidentielle il y
a une il y avait une demande d'une
gauche en France elle existe toujours
pour l'instant elle voit pas très bien
où s'incarner alliance de circonstances
pas ma joue pose la question à vous
Alexia
au début très clairement mais après vous
savez pour l'instant ça tient pour
l'instant ça tient ça ne s'est pas
fracasser sur les les projets de loi les
uns après les autres alors on va voir
parce que là c'est la rentrée donc bon
tout le monde reprend ses marques
et puis je crois beaucoup que le
collectif vous savez à un moment arrive
à trouver sa place de lui-même en
d'autres termes cette
cet alliance qui était que de
circonstances les gens vont apprendre à
travailler ensemble aussi c'est la
politique c'est aussi beaucoup d'humains
donc je pense que ce serait présomptueux
de dire que ce n'est qu'une alliance de
circonstance au fur et à mesure
évidemment il y aura les difficultés
électorales parce que les scrutins de
liste comme les européennes ça va être
extrêmement compliqué de réconcilier des
gens qui qui ne sont vraiment pas sur la
même ligne mais il n'y a pas que les
élections il y a aussi la vie
parlementaire traditionnelle et pour la
vie parlementaire traditionnelle c'est
l'intérêt bien compris de tout le monde
de faire tenir finalement cette alliance
de circonstances voilà c'est un mariage
de raison alors dans un baromètre de ça
c'est tellement riche qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à aborder on va
maintenant se concentrer sur la
popularité la cote de popularité
d'adhésion
d'Elizabeth borne alors on regarde celle
d'Emmanuel Macron d'abord puis celle
d'Elisabeth borne j'espère que vous
allez me suivre c'est le d'Emmanuel
Macron diriez-vous qu'emel Macron est un
bon Président de la République non à 59%
oui à 41% avec une progression de trois
points pour le président et voici
maintenant la cote de popularité
d'Elisabeth borne même question
direz-vous qu'ils avaient debor est une
bonne première ministre le nom est un
peu plus puissant 57 % le oui et bien
elle fait le jeu = maintenant avec le
président grâce à une hausse de 8 points
Frédéric potiers comment vous vous
analysez ce rebond alors c'est vrai
qu'on avait des interrogations sortir
des élections législatives puisque en
marche n'avait pas eu cette majorité et
on se demandait si Elisabeth borne
allait pouvoir faire face à cette
coalition et cette coalition des
oppositions en fait elle a eu un été
plutôt solide je trouve qu'elle sort
plutôt renforcée de cet été là sur le
front des incendies elle a su aussi
tenir tête un certain nombre de barons
de piliers du gouvernement imposer un
style aussi en fait un style fait de
sérieux de crédibilité maintenant la
rentrée elle a pas vraiment commencé la
rentrée parlementaire elle commence à la
semaine prochaine et c'est là où les
ennuis vont commencer pour la majorité
parce qu'il y a le budget il y a
potentiellement le sujet des retraites
il y a les plans de sobriété aussi
énergétiques qui vont arriver avec
l'hiver qui va arriver en même temps et
donc voilà je pense que on aurait tort à
Matignon de se livrer à un certain
triomphalistes un peu prématuré
alors j'ai pas regardé la mentalisée
dans la ventilation sympathisante gauche
ou de droite elle est où est-ce qu'elle
est la plus particulière en fait c'est
assez remarquable quand même le ce qui
arrive avec Elizabeth borne je précise
donc que vous vous l'avez fait après que
c'était entre l'été et maintenant la
dernière mesure date juste d'après l'été
une période où c'était la cata puisque
en gros nouvelle exécutisme en fait
c'est pas vraiment du nouveau puisque
Macron était réélu se retrouver avec des
niveaux très bas pour le président mais
encore plus pour la première ministre
les premières prises de position
intervention d'Elisabeth borne ont donné
un sentiment de flottement
deux elle aura peut-être pas l'envergure
elle aura peut-être pas les épaules et
donc elle est partie de très bas et là
elle réussit une rem en flèche et pour
vous répondre ce qui est remarquable
c'est la poussée et en plus le fait que
elle est une majorité de jugement
positifs chez les sympathisants de tous
les parties dites de gouvernement aussi
bien europécologie les Verts le PS donc
à gauche qu'à droite LR ok il y a du
rejet chez les sympathisants des
extrêmes mais il est pas si violent que
ça non plus compte tenu de leur rejet
par exemple d'un Emmanuel Macron et elle
arrive à être populaire auprès de ces
sympathisants là et donc je souscris
tout à fait à ce que vous avez dit sur
le fait qu'elle a très bien géré les
choses dans l'opinion qu'elle a su se
faire elle a gagné être connu en quelque
sorte et je rejoins aussi ce que vous
venez de dire sur les nuages sombres qui
arrivent en termes de projet de réforme
de sujet parce que vous l'avez dit je
reviendrai pas dessus mais les retraites
c'est très un peu plus l'air la réforme
de l'assurance chômage vous l'avez pas
évoqué mais ça arrive aussi sur ça va
arriver sur le devant de la scène ce
sera probablement un populaire ou en
tout cas ce sera clivant et donc elle
sera dans une situation elle devra
affronter des vents mauvais mais il vaut
mieux le faire en ces temps un peu
réconcilié avec qu'en étant partie de
son niveau d'avant l'été j'ajoute que en
trajectoire
elle ressemble un petit peu on avait
parlé avant l'été ensemble parce qu'elle
était très basse et on se disait mais
bon est-ce que c'est condamné bah non
regardez Édouard Philippe et là ça
ressemble tout à fait à ce qui avait
vécu Édouard Philippe dans nos sondages
on s'amusait c'était méchant mais de
poser la question et comment s'appelait
le comment s'appelle le Premier ministre
en question ouverte et on voyait des
gens nous dire Gérard Philipe enfin se
planter complètement il était
complètement inconnu et donc d'une
personnalité inconnue et qui suscitait
peu d'adhésion il a réussi à s'affirmer
progressivement comme un premier
ministre préféré à son président puis
aujourd'hui comme la personnalité
politique préférée des Français depuis
qu'il est quitté Matignon c'est
peut-être ce destin là qui attend
Elisabeth borne donc Elisabeth borne est
très très bien conseillée parce qu'elle
était sur un siège éjectable après les
législatives elle l'a compris elle a
orchestré une opération communication
tout l'été qui était réussi mais qui
était vraiment fourni elle a fait une
quinzaine d'interviews tout azimut et on
voit que effectivement ça permet de
l'asseoir avant cette rentrée sociale
qui s'annonce euh là vous êtes un peu
aussi gentil tout ça parce que c'est
jeudi la première manifestation hein
contre les retraites donc là c'est cette
semaine que ça commence et c'est cette
semaine ça t'a démarre il vaut mieux
être bien assise populaire
ou au moins connu allez c'est Germain
est-ce que vous faites-vous aussi le
parallèle avec Édouard Philippe ce que
je trouve très intéressant c'est d'abord
sur la la méconnaissance des Français au
départ donc finalement on apprend à
découvrir une personnalité et ce qui est
intéressant dans le cas d'Elizabeth
borne c'est que les Français qui la
connaissaient la percevait comme une
femme et effectivement très compétente
mais donc une techno comme on dit et cet
été la séquence de cet été a permis de
démontrer que c'était aussi une femme
politique à part entière avec des
réflexes de femmes politiques et qui
s'est sécurisé les côtés sur lesquels il
faut sécuriser mettre en avant un
certain nombre de sujets en même temps
sur le fond des dossiers en ayant la
compétence et la légitimité pour le
faire parce qu'elle est arrivée en étant
inconnue mais les Français la
créditaient quand même alors je sais pas
si vous pouviez le tester mais d'une
certaine légitimité sur les dossiers sur
lesquels elle était puisqu'elle de
sérieux voilà de sérieux
elle était complètement inconnue
contrairement Édouard Philippe elle
était peu connue ou méconnue
ça patte elle imprime un style aussi qui
n'est pas forcément un steam un style
très flamboyant mais qui est un style
extrêmement solide
l'adjectif qui vient en premier c'est
solide c'est très solide voilà et après
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec la politique qu'elle mène ça je
rentre pas là-dessus mais c'est vrai que
elle est en train de créer un lien après
il y a de nombreuses écueils aussi sur
le devant de la route là parce que les
l'histoire sérieuse commence maintenant
on va retenir cette expression merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce à
ce débat bientôt évidemment sur ce
plateau de sens public